en este vídeo nos vamos a concentrar en
resolver ejercicios acerca de la
pendiente de una recta
sólo para recordar brevemente la
pendiente es una medida de qué tan
inclinada se encuentra una línea recta
la definición formal de pendiente es
pendiente es igual al cambio en que
entre el cambio en x esta fórmula puede
parecer algo intimidante pero por ello
vamos a hacer muchos ejemplos para que
se vuelva algo familiar vamos a empezar
con esta línea con la línea a así que
vamos a encontrar la pendiente de la
línea a en esta gráfica ya tenemos
marcados dos puntos que podemos usar
como nuestros puntos de referencia lo
primero que hay que hacer es encontrar
las coordenadas cuáles son las
coordenadas de este punto acá arriba
pues socorren a x estrés y su coordenada
ya es 6 ahora este punto de trabajo
tiene coordenada x menos 1 aquí está
menos 1 y su coordenada ya es menos 6
hay varias cosas que podríamos hacer
para calcular la pendiente de una recta
la forma más sencilla es usar la fórmula
directamente el cambio entre el cambio
en x
ahora tenemos que saber cuánto valen
estas
comenzamos con el cambio en lo que
necesitamos averiguar es cuánto cambió
nuestra coordenada y al pasar del punto
inicial al punto final así que cuánto
cambió nuestra coordenada y pues
empezamos al menos 6 y subimos hasta 6
positivo así que lo que estamos buscando
es esta longitud y lo que hacemos es
tomar el punto de final la coordenada 10
del punto final y le restamos la
coordenada del punto inicial menos seis
así que 6 menos menos 6 que es lo mismo
que seis más 6 que es 12 por supuesto
también habríamos podido contar en la
gráfica 9 10 11 12 así que el cambio
fue de 12 ahora necesitamos saber qué
cambio de x le corresponde así que
cuánto es el cambio en x en este caso
pues empezamos en menos 1 y avanzamos
hasta 3
así que el cambio fue de menos 1 a 3 el
valor de x final fue 3 y el valor de x
inicial fue de menos 1 así que 3 menos
menos uno que es tres más uno que es
cuatro así que el cambio de intercambio
en x es 12 entre 4 y si simplificamos
esta fracción nos da 3 ahora qué quiere
decir esto geométricamente pues lo que
representa la pendiente digamos el
cambio en el cambio en x que en este
caso es 3 que es lo mismo que 3 entre 1
nos dice que si avanzamos una unidad en
la dirección x positiva entonces
avanzamos tres unidades en la dirección
diapositiva es decir si nos vamos a una
unidad la derecha subimos tres unidades
una a la derecha tres unidades hacia
arriba y si ahora avanzaremos dos
unidades a la derecha entonces
subiríamos seis unidades
6 entre 2 nos da 3 que de nuevo es la
pendiente y lo que nos dice la pendiente
es qué tan rápido crece y en relación a
x muy bien pues ahora continuamos con el
ejemplo de la línea ve muy bien así que
ahora hacemos la línea b voy a usar los
puntos que nos dieron aquí pero en
realidad podría usar cualesquiera dos
puntos sobre la recta
vamos a ver primero este punto que es el
punto 0 1
y luego este otro punto el punto inicial
va a ser
es menos 6 coma
- 2 así que bueno la misma idea que
antes cuál es el cambio y para un cambio
en x primero vamos a hacer el cambio en
x así que cuál es nuestro cambio en x
y bueno aquí en la gráfica podría contar
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis así que
el cambio en x va a ser 6 pero
imagínense que no tenemos la gráfica
entonces lo que haríamos es tomamos
nuestra posición x terminal o x final y
le quitamos nuestra posición de x
inicial menos seis así que cero menos
menos seis así que nuestro cambio en x
ese dispositivo y nuestro cambio en ya
cual es así que primero que nada
recuerden que este es nuestro punto
final 01 es nuestro punto final y el -6
menos 2 es nuestro punto inicial así que
ahora tenemos que tomar
1 - menos 2
menos -2 que es 12 así que esto nos da 3
y por lo tanto nuestra pendiente es 3
sextos o lo que es lo mismo un medio así
que si nos movemos en la dirección x 6
unidades positivas subimos tres unidades
en la dirección y así que nuestro cambio
en yen fue 3 nuestro cambio en x fue de
6 algo que muchas veces confunde a la
gente es cuál de los dos puntos es el
final y cuál es el inicial por ejemplo
como sobre tomar este serio y de
restarle al menos 6 y luego tomar este 1
y de ahí restarle al menos 2 la
respuesta es que no importa por ejemplo
podemos repetir este procedimiento pero
ahora considerando al menos 6 como al
menos 2 como nuestro punto final y
entonces el cambio en que es el valor
final del que es menos 2 menos mi valor
inicial de ya que es 1
entonces tengo menos dos menos 1 y mi
valor final de x que es menos 6 menos mi
valor inicial de x que es cero
entonces obtengo lo mismo que antes sólo
que ahora tengo un signo negativo es
decir menos 2 - 1 es menos tres dividido
entre menos 6 -0 que es menos 6 y de
nuevo tengo un medio porque los menos se
cancelan así que realmente no es
importante sólo hay que ser consistente
si considero este como mi igual mi valor
de final entonces este tiene que ser mi
valor de x final si ahora considero el
uno como el valor del final entonces el
cero debe también ser mi valor de x
final pero si tengo eso en cuenta
siempre obtengo el mismo resultado
de hecho se puede ver geométricamente en
este caso la pendiente este menos 6 nos
indica que si recorremos menos 6
unidades en las x es decir si nos vamos
6 unidades a la izquierda entonces
debemos bajar 3 unidades este menos 3 de
acá y es lo mismo que una pendiente de
un medio que nos diría que por cada 2
unidades que recorren x tengo que subir
una unidad o cada 2 unidades hacia atrás
tengo que bajar una unidad y de nuevo la
pendiente es un medio noten como la
recta con pendiente un medio es
muchísimo menos inclinada que la recta
con pendiente 3 muy bien hagamos un par
de ejemplos más vamos a hacer ahora la
línea c aquí la línea
la voy a hacer en rosado y de nuevo voy
a tomar los puntos que ya me dieron
sobre la línea voy a usar este punto y
este punto mi punto inicial es el menos
16 y mi punto final
55 65 -6 entonces bueno
cuánto vale nuestra pendiente cuánto
vale la pendiente la recta pues es el
cambio en que el cambio en d
/ el cambio en x y esto a veces se llama
el alza entre el avance en el avance es
el avance en la dirección x y el alza es
cuanto subimos en la dirección y
entonces bueno nuestro cambio en que es
nuestra coordenada 10 final
- nuestra coordenada inicial
así que esto es nuestra coordenada final
y esta es nuestra cordón área inicial
sobre nuestra coordenadas x final entre
nuestra coordenada x inicial y realmente
lo único que estoy diciendo es que esto
vale menos 6 menos 6 entre nuestra
coordenada x final que es 5 - nuestra
cuerda en la x inicial que es menos 1
así que esto nos da menos 66 es menos 12
entre 5 menos menos uno se vuelve 6
entonces menos 2 entre 6 que es lo mismo
que menos 2 así que la pendiente es
menos 2 y esto se debe a que cada vez
que avanza uno de la dirección x tengo
que bajar 2 en la dirección así que esto
es una pendiente negativa y significa
que la línea va de la esquina superior
izquierda a la esquina inferior derecha
así que podemos pensar que mientras la x
crece la que decrece con este
razonamiento la línea debería tener una
pendiente positiva
de nuevo es todo un salto dos puntos que
ya me dieron
así que vamos a hacer la línea de la
pendiente es igual al alza entre el
avance cuanto me alcé y cuanto avance al
pasar de este punto al otro pues alce
con subí cuántas unidades 2 3 4 5 6
unidades mi avance es de 6 unidades y
cuánto perdón me alzas de 6 unidades y
cuánto es mi avance y avance es 123456
mi avance es de 6
así que nuestra pendiente 6 entre 6 debe
ser 1 y eso nos dice que cada vez que
avanzando en la dirección x sube 1 en la
dirección y si digamos lo que hiciera
fuera retroceder si retrocedo dos
unidades entonces bajo dos unidades
entonces lo que hagamos en x lo tenemos
que hacer en g
así que esta recta estuvo bastante
sencilla si quisiéramos hacerlo
formalmente matemáticamente entonces
tendríamos que encontrar las coordenadas
de estos puntos nuestro punto inicial
sería
- 2 - 4 y nuestro punto final sería él
42 y entonces nuestra pendiente es el
cambio
entre el cambio en x y eso es lo mismo
que dos menos -4 entre 4 - menos 2
menos dos así que esto nos da 24 es 246
y
eso es simplemente la distancia que
recorre y en la dirección de entre 4 -
menos dos que es otros seis y esto nos
da la pendiente de uno muy bien vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo esto está bastante
interesante vamos a hacer la línea de
nuestra línea y bueno el cambio entre el
cambio mx queremos encontrar la
pendiente
cuánto vale nuestro cambio en y al
movernos de ese punto a ese punto pues
si lo contamos es 5 6 7 8 8 unidades o
podríamos tomar simplemente esta
coordenadas que 2 - está acordonada ya
que es menos 62 menos 6 que es 8 y cuál
es el cambio en x pues nuestro valor de
x aquí es 4 y nuestro valor de x aquí es
4 así que no hubo cambio en x el cambio
x es cero entonces cuánto vale 8 entre 0
pues realmente no está definido así que
en este caso cuando tenemos una línea
vertical decimos que la pendiente está
indefinida entonces si la pendiente está
indefinida lo que pasa es que no hay
cambio en x y podemos
que se trata de una línea vertical bien
pues vamos a hacer este último ejemplo
de la línea f y este se ve bastante
sencillo entonces tengo ese punto que
tiene coordenadas 3,1 la línea f y tengo
el punto 31 y también tengo este otro
punto que tiene coordenadas menos seis
coma menos 2
ahora cuánto vale la pendiente de la
línea f pues como siempre es el cambio
entre el cambio en x ahora para hacer
las cosas distintas voy a tomar el menos
seis como menos 2 como mi punto final
entonces el cambio en g ahora es un
descenso y vale menos dos menos uno
eso es muy afín al menos milla inicial
menos dos menos uno que es menos tres y
ahora tengo que dividir entre el cambio
en x pero el cambio mx ahora es un
retroceso es un retroceso de cuántas
unidades como también menos dos como mi
valor final de y ahora tengo que tomar
el menos seis como mi x final
2 - 6 menos 3 y esto vale menos 9
entonces tengo una pendiente menos 3 /
menos 9 y lo que significa es que si
retrocedo 9 unidades si no voy 9
unidades a la izquierda entonces bajo 3
unidades que es exactamente lo mismo que
decir si avanzo 9 unidades
subo 3 los menos se cancelan y obtengo
una pendiente de un tercio así que la
pendiente es positiva y como siempre
significa que si avanzo 3 unidades a la
derecha entonces hubo una unidad
si avanzo 3 a la derecha entonces subo
una y bueno espero que esto haya sido un
buen repaso de los conceptos de
pendiente